yesterday this was a house and yareta
family took shelter inside from the
coming storm but they were lying in the
path of a tornado
part of the massive weather system of
Typhoon Haiyan Oh
[Applause]
so you need an attorney
miraculously they all emerged unscathed
from the wreckage now they're salvaging
what they can show or hide your hunch or
let me know along with police
firefighters and the Japan Coast Guard
27,000 self-defense forces personnel are
currently undertaking rescue and relief
activities when necessary we will
enforce such measures also in order to
recover the damage in infrastructures
such as power outage water outage
suspension and transportation services
at the earliest possible timing we will
continue to work with the related
government institutions and agencies
this whole village east of Tokyo bears
the scars of the tornado cars were
swatted aside by the high winds leading
to one person losing their life
many residents sheltered inside this
summer shrine it too took a battering
but no one was hurt it is now a bright
and sunny day and that's good news on
two fronts first of all there's less
chance of further wind or rain damage
making this situation worse a second
they can get on with the cleanup
operation which they're doing diligently
but I mean just look at the force here
this whole house has been completely
leveled there are the pieces of people's
lives people's whole lives among the
ruins rescue efforts continued around
Japan
flooding north of Tokyo had left many
stranded last night's typhoon was
violent and deadly he was thought to be
the biggest in more than 60 years and it
drove a furrow through japan's northeast
coast alongside the fatalities many
people are still missing but Japan has
not wasted a second with the recovery
this whole village has suffered this
whole village will put itself back
together
Tom Cheshire Sky News Chiba